hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my flash episode 6 video enter
zoom so so many Easter eggs so much fun
Linda stuff so let's get going just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet there is a new round of
the reverse flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so here we go starting with top 5
WTF quick dadburn so Jessie quick on
earth to finds out that her dad Harrison
wells of earth 2 created all the
metahumans and it seems like he just
doesn't want to tell everyone about it
because of hubris like it might be his
hubris that leads to the rise of zoom
like he keeps trying to place blame on
Jay Garrick like oh he's not he's not
enough of a hero but my Jessie always so
quick figures things out so she's like
okay I get it you're kind of a dirtbag
dad but I still love you most of this
gets tied up in Cisco trying to vibe on
him which I think it's funny the way
they use that term did you vibe on me
what did you vibe on me Cisco go try to
touch him again it's just the writers
slowly humanizing this dickbag version
of Harrison wells
I thought the serial killer version
would have been a bigger jerk but on the
number 4 earth to Oliver Queen shout out
so this is where they go into flashpoint
territory if you ever saw the animated
movie or read the comic Thomas Wayne
becomes Batman instead of Bruce because
Bruce died they do the Queen's Gambit
like in the background on the news and
it's like a twist on that they do the
Thomas Wayne thing so maybe Green Arrow
over to is Robert Queen that was just
fun I would expect to get more earth to
Easter eggs for characters that we know
on earth one already
just like little jokes or things on the
newscast like the way they did this
Green Arrow thing on the number three
though dr. light training montage best
training montage ever there were so many
funny moments how long you been keeping
these around well you got to have hobby
I love that Cisco make cardboard cutouts
of team flash and just had them sitting
around in a warehouse like how long had
those existed melis gel was so much fun
playing Linda Park trying to play earth
to Linda Park dr. light they get into
Tropic Thunder territory on the dude
play in the dude pretended to be the
other dude and just for reference earth
to dr. light she only escaped because
she took her costume off and was able to
use her powers that means she's naked
running around somewhere so somewhere on
earth one if you keep your eyes peeled
you might see naked Linda Park maybe
maybe on the DVD bonus features maybe
that hit the cutting room
fluor on to number two though fake dr.
light versus Barry Allen so this is so
much fun it's like Linda performing it's
like she's performing theater did I do
it okay did I do it get that time now
bring it back a little bit little too
much a little too much that time then
she does take down Barry and leans in
really close are you okay
you still okay like it's like okay of
course zoom is probably watching this
somehow which is the real question like
obviously zoom knew that that was gonna
happen so he waited for them to disperse
and came in later you like to use bait
to fish I like to use bait too so it
goes from super comedy like one of the
funniest episodes of the flash ever to
one of the scariest episodes ever my
number one WTF Barry versus zoom this is
actually a really good fight for as
short as it was it's kind of like what
you hoped to have seen with the
reverse-flash and Barry last year but
what they never really got to like they
never got to those big prolonged fights
because Barry wasn't that good as the
flash yet and even as good as he's
gotten since last season he exists kind
of in the same power and balance with
zoom reverse-flash season one way better
than Barry Season one zoom season two
also a lot better than Barry season two
so he throws the lightning back at him
but Barry does kind of defeat him with
science for a brief moment like the
terminal velocity fix but bazoom beating
Barry like parading him around town like
look at your God here he's no God your
Flash is dead it's almost like he wants
to rub the world's nose in it he wants
everyone to see that he is the best it's
almost like the hubris of earth -
Harrison wells who we know for sure is
not zoom now like earth - Harrison wells
wasn't able to admit his mistake look I
caused this huge explosion created all
these metahumans created all these
problems zoom wants everyone to
acknowledge his greatness it's not
enough that he is the fastest he wants
everyone to see him being the fastest
just something to think about when your
theory crafting zoom just as he's ready
to kill Barry though Cisco is able to
get him with the serum and zoom runs
away before it takes effect
so it's you know temporary victory but
the interesting thing is that Barry se
wakes up cannot feel his legs so I think
what's going to happen is is we're going
to see an episode where Barry just is
out of commission and next week is the
gorilla grodd episode so they're
probably have to find a way to defeat
Grodd without Barry having his
SuperSpeed and just a reminder episode 8
is going to be the big arrow crossover
so episode 8 of the flash will come for
that'll be the first part of the
crossover it'll be the Vandal Savage
episode then the second part of that
will be arrow episode 8 like the next
night so it'll be like a - our short
movie for legends of tomorrow it'll
it'll completely set up what's going on
with legends of tomorrow that's what
this picture is all about now notice the
gloves that Barry is wearing that
obviously has something to do with the
plot of the episode but this picture is
from the second part of that the arrow
half so the real question is is very
going to get the use of his legs back at
the end of the Grodd episode or is he
going to get it back during the
crossover episode but what I'm going to
do is I'll talk a little bit more about
that Grodd episode when I post a trailer
video later in the week that there's so
much we could talk about about that it's
going to be kind of like a King Kong
episode with Caitlin snow but let me
know in the comments what was you guys
favorite moment from the episode was it
just watching Barry go up against zoom
like seeing all the crazy stuff zoom can
do we've only seen the beginning of his
powers actually Daniel Pennebaker did an
interview where she was teasing the zoom
has a bunch of abilities that we haven't
seen yet so just expect zoom to do
something even more spectacular in a
future episode you know probably the
mid-season crossover but just some other
really awesome things about the episode
that didn't really fit into my top 5 so
you have Patti here on the outside she's
one of the few people that doesn't know
anything about what's going on with team
flash and she had that conversation with
Joe where he's like look I'm involved
with this yeah but I'm not dirty just
give me a couple days trust me and then
she goes to bear and she's like want to
do something tonight and he's like oh I
got a I got a thing with Joe tonight so
you can see the wheels turning in her
head like she figures out that Barry's
hiding something from her but as far as
I can tell patty still doesn't find out
that she's the flash it leaves through
the mid-season finale I don't know if
that's going to happen in episode 9 or
if they're going to save that for the
second half of the season
definitely not as long as they stretched
the iris West reveal in season 1 I think
they learned their lesson like that okay
we're not going to drag it out that long
but patty has that funny moment where
she's like I'm not baby crazy and all I
could think about was Wally West and
Linda parks children but but obviously
like Barry and Patty aren't gonna be
having babies or anything like that but
any time people talk about having babies
with the flash you just you think of
Wally West's children and then there was
irises moment at the end before zoom
came along where she and Linda were
talking well if we're going to be on
Team flash we better start going to
CrossFit or something like that let me
know do you guys think if Linda Park
were to actually like formally join team
flash and start helping out solving
crimes do you think that she
should keep the doctor light name or she
should take something else because in
the comics she's always just Linda Park
there was kind of that Gwen Stacy Green
Goblin moment with Linda but obviously
that's Marvel so I don't think that
that's what they were going for it's
just that any time a villain holds a
heroine over a building and drops her
you think of Green Goblin Gwen Stacy now
what's going to happen next is is
there's a new Jessica Jones trailer so
I'll post that hopefully in the next
like 6 to 12 hours it'll probably be
Wednesday morning then I'll do arrow
then I'll do agents of shield and then
I'm probably going to do Supergirl on
Thursday so forearm on track to do
everything but I should be posting
updates on Twitter and Facebook there
are links for that at the bottom of the
description while you guys wait for
everything to post you can click here
for the last Star Wars trailer that I
just posted they just posted like a
longer clip with Han Solo and Rey and
you can click here for my flash season 2
playlist thank you so much for watching
everybody let's at five I'll see you
guys tonight